DEVASTATING DAY IN HISTORY.
BACK TO "HANNITY."
>> ♪ ♪
>> ON THE FISA APPLICATION, YOU
HEARD COMEY CALL IT A MOSAIC.
PEOPLE NEED TO SEE WHAT'S THERE.
I THINK THEY WOULD CRINGE IF
THEY KNEW WHAT THE GOVERNMENT
WAS WILLING TO DO TO IS THES.
>> Sean: DEVIN NUNES LAST NIGHT
DISCUSSING FISA ABUSE TO SPY ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
JIM COMEY SAID WE DIDN'T SPY BUT
HE SIGNED THE FIRST VAST
WARRANT.
-- FISA WARRANT.
YOUR NEXT GUEST, I KNOW THIS
IMPACTED YOU.
YOU LIVED THROUGH IT BUT YOU
WERE BEING USED AS A CONDIUT
INTO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN BUT YOU
WERE SPIED ON HOW MANY TIMES?
>> THERE WERE FOUR APPLICATIONS.
WHO KNOWS?
THE DETAILS KEEP COMING OUT, IT
KEEPS GETTING WORSE AND WORSE.
WE SHALL SEE.
>> Sean: LOOK, ONE AMERICAN
CITIZEN, THESE ARE
CONSTITUTIONAL LIBERTIES.
IT BOTHERS ME SHORT OF ALAN
DERSHOWITZ AND DOUG, NOT MANY ON
THE LEFT SEEM TO CARE.
IT'S LIKE THE ENDS JUSTIFY THE
MEANS.
WHAT DO YOU WANT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO KNOW NOW THAT YOU WERE
A VICTIM?
>> MY FEELINGS, IT WAS NOT AN
ATTACK ON ME.
IT WAS AN ATTACK ON CANDIDATE
TRUMP AND THE TRUMP MOVEMENT.
IT CONTINUED AS PRESIDENT ELECT
TRUMP AND HIS NEW
ADMINISTRATION.
THAT'S THE GREATEST DAMAGE.
>> Sean: HOW MANY TIMES DID
HALPERMEET WITH YOU?
>> I LOST TRACK.
>> Sean: DID YOU KNOW HE WAS
THERE TO SPY ON YOU?
>> NO, IT WAS AT A POINT IN MY
LIFE WHEN I WAS UNDER SO MUCH
PRESSURE WITH THESE FALSE
STORIES STARTING IN SEPTEMBER
2016.
I WAS SHUNNED BY EVERYONE EXCEPT
FOR A FEW FAMILY MEMBERS AND
PRESS.
>> Sean: THE INTEL COMMUNITY?
>> IT WAS EXPOSED THAT I WAS AN
INFORMANT FOR THE CIA AND THE
FBI.
IT'S FUNNY BECAUSE THE REPORTS
WITH BRENNAN AND CLAPPER SAYING
WE DON'T WANT TO EXPOSE
INFORMANTS.
THEY TALKED ABOUT A RUSSIAN
BASEED IN NEW YORK THAT I WAS
GIVING INFORMATION TO THE FBI
ABOUT.
>> Sean: WHEN THEY INTERVIEWED
YOU, THEY KNEW YOU DID NOTHING